the Joe Rogan experience yeah now what
is it with it with Mme what are what are
the big nationalities that's a good
question Russians Russians are murdering
it right now there's a lot of badass
Russia's wherever what life is hard I'm
gonna find fighters and you're gonna
find people that survive where life is
hard and thrive and then that's how you
get like a khabib nurmagomedov you get a
hard [ __ ] who knows how to fight
and then it scares [ __ ]
same thing with Conor McGregor you get a
hard neighborhood a hard life you know
growing up in Dublin dangerous fighting
since he was young you know that's how
you get these beasts and then a lot of
American MMA guys come from wrestling or
the military right yeah some of them
some of them from the military you know
it's rare you know we had special forces
guy like Tim Kennedy of course who's
probably one the most famous Brian Stann
also military veteran and you look at
these guys that are you know the guys
that are capable being seals or Rangers
or Green Berets they're just elite
humans they're just they're people that
know how to do things and push
themselves in a way that other people
don't
sometimes that translates over the
fighting sometimes doesn't yeah
you know sometimes they just don't have
the physical capability of it like they
might have the mindset to survive war
and the ability to get through buds and
to get through grueling physical
training but you ain't being John Jones
you know like there's just levels to
this thing there's genetic levels you
know John Jones says like some of the
best genetics ever and then uses them as
good as anybody that's ever existed best
at controlling distance of all time he's
got two brothers or NFL players so this
like super genetics and they're right
both his brothers are NFL stars that's
amazing and he's the baddest light
heavyweight of all time any smart so
it's not just physical it's also
intellectual he's also sets traps for
people he measures them he sees what
they're doing and he fails him weakening
he pressures and puts heavy pressure on
people he knows when to ebb and flow
he's just a genius at fighting do
lightweights have longer careers no no I
would say the opposite I would say the
bigger guys actually have they can
compete at a higher level deep into
their 30s and even 40s a grand eco-tour
I think I think Yuri won
Heavyweight I died when he was 42
checkers I would think there's be more
knockouts with heavyweights is a lot of
knockouts with every ways but they their
bodies maintain what got them to the
dance later in life
like George Foreman George Foreman won
the heavyweight title I think he was 46
when he knocked out Michael Moore so the
oldest ever Heavyweight Champion and
that's just unheard of at welterweight
you're not gonna see 46 year old
welterweights winning the world title
against Earl Spence tune yourself out
you're just not gonna see that 43 he was
43 brandi was yeah and find out how old
George Foreman was when he knocked out
Michael Moore
so that's crazy that's crazy old 43 yeah
you don't see that at 125 pounds you
just don't you just don't 125 pounds no
one wins the title at 43 so just the
mass almost helps you survive something
like that I also think they lose less as
they get older
who is 44 45 so yeah George Foreman was
the oldest ever Heavyweight Champion at
45 crazy Wow you know like that is so
unusual as like a middleweight the only
one who maintained a world championship
caliber skill set deep into his 40s was
Bernard Hopkins and Archie Moore when
Archie Moore was younger in Memphis you
know we're talking about the rocky
marciano days that was he fought deep
into his 40s as well but he was just a
real crafty veteran he actually also
trained George Foreman which is very
interesting
so like that crafty veteran trained
George Foreman to be a crafty veteran
yeah and maintain his power he had a
real unusual remember but George Foreman
used to almost like put his hands up
like he didn't know how to fight yeah
almost like that but that was his
defense he would move forward like this
because he was so big he was such an
enormous man with these enormous arms so
when he would stack them on top of each
other and walk towards you like that it
was just weird offense and he learned
that from Archie Moore that's part of
the part of his defense and holding his
hands up in a weird way he learned from
Archie Moore right well you know the
oldest hockey player in the NHL is the
also the biggest six foot eight the guy
is a Dana Chara
ruins 43 what's that name what is his
name is it Dana Chara what Slovakian
yeah hehe that dude was from the Lord of
the Rings listen to that name they gave
birth to him in a meadow
they rode a horse out there it was
destiny they predict how long yeah this
that name he [ __ ] Viking he's an
animal
he fights I saw oh yeah I saw this one
fight where he hit a guy and the guy
kind of took a dive and he he leaned
down and picked him up with one hand and
started punching him with the other
lifted him off the ice with on hand on
yeah I saw one thing that a guy did
that's really [ __ ] up a guy hip tossed
a dude he judo threw him like he swept
him like he grabbed ahold of him
swept his leg out kicked his leg out
like Yamato and slammed his [ __ ] head
onto the ground
he's rough yeah yeah I was like man that
ain't the same as fighting like you know
you're on ice yeah no one told him he
couldn't do it right but he used some
really [ __ ] sneaky [ __ ] yeah you know
yeah they fighting in the nan chat is
funny there's a there's really great
clips of guys talking to each other
before fights mmm and it's amazingly
calm they literally go like hey you want
to go and the guy will be like y'all go
and then they fight and then they three
and then as soon as when the other guy
goes eeeh they just throw their gloves
down and they start fighting it's all
it's all part of the game it's all
[ __ ] orchestrated and there's players
that fight and there's players that
don't and if you're on it if you're on
the ice with another goon then it's it's
expected that you guys are gonna fight
at some point yeah what a crazy way to
make a living bare-knuckle fighting on
slippery floor yeah but you know they
don't they don't get hit that much
because they get to cheers he up they do
they can hit enough though yeah I've
been watching dudes who have skills now
you're seeing way more guys who have
boxing skills right doing this yeah guys
who like laying like short uppercuts
right f talks where you like oh my god I
gotta turn that punch over that guy
knows how to punch yeah there's not as
many over hands so you're all you're
doing with the overhand
a helmet with your fists yeah the
flailing sometimes you don't see that
sometimes you've seen guys who throw
[ __ ] straight punches yeah all right
you don't know how to fight it and then
this guy knows how to do that while he's
out yeah this one look at this boom boom
your vest cannot happen at home wow
that's a good KO while he's holed and
then he gives him one was going down and
he goes down he's out cold boom boom
yeah right from the shoulder oh yeah
that guy can punch Hey and he's you're
punching in the face while he's punching
you in the face - it's chaos it's a
terrible way to fight not only a great
fighter one of the best players in
league and also and also a great fighter
wow that's a crazy sport man doesn't get
enough love yeah name the get the
average person name a famous hockey
players currently playing no this is the
same guy this crazy thing happened this
year this is an insane video to watch I
can't show it every people out of home
I've might have seen this but the puck
literally flies and hits him right in
the face and he barely moves as I should
show it again in slow motion right here
you check to see if his teeth got
knocked out oh man you got bucked right
in the mug yeah bro that is hard wow
that guy can take it [ __ ] it not do you
know the [ __ ] Bruins and actually
dropped Game one last night against the
Blues but the Bruins are set to win the
Stanley Cup which means Boston will win
the [ __ ] Super Bowl the World Series
and the Stanley Cup in one year I
remember when we lived there they
couldn't win chow it was like they had
such an inferiority complex
yeah and they would get close like the
Celtics are good at Larry Bird and Danny
they have it forever
cuz like when was the last time though
the Yankees won the World Series how
long ago was that she's 2008 so it's
been 11 years I know I could be way off
on that but they still have it there's
still the Yankees you know yeah but for
the Red Sox
they never pulled it off and then that
Bill Buckner thing
Bill Buckner just died no so sad so and
that's the thing about being in bought
because I grew up a Mets fan we had
season tickets to the met since I was a
little kid and so when they got into the
World Series and I was going to school
in Boston
surrounded by Massholes watching these
[ __ ] games and they're just I'm sorry
if you're from Boston take it the [ __ ]
easy about your sports there so like
like like last night with the with the
Bruins game they they boo the entire
they introduced a that lose they boo
every [ __ ] player it's just it's
barbaric they're animals
so then [ __ ] Buckner who's this
storied amazing player who's a
journeyman he's been out there forever
they put him at first base he used to be
an outfielder but he he slowed down I
think he had bad legs or something put
him at first base he gets a [ __ ] ball
hit to him it it took a bad hop watch
the video it took a bad hop and he
missed it and they [ __ ] there were
death threats they dropped him that year
he went down a pot Tucket in Rhode
Island to playing the minors they showed
up there and [ __ ] terrorized them he
had to move out to like Arizona to hide
because these [ __ ] Boston fans I
remember people walk in the streets what
year was that eighty 46 City six I
remember people walking the streets they
just be walking around the neighborhood
with their hands in their hair like [ __ ]
yeah after they lost [ __ ] yes walk in
the street yeah yeah we're so mad it was
all anybody wanted to talk about alright
because they hadn't won a World Series
since 2017 or something oh it was crazy
I was already 2000 1917 yeah 1917 I was
already over baseball at that point I
wasn't interested in baseball anymore so
for me it was really fascinating to
watch yeah watch these people cuz I had
gone from caring about baseball to being
obsessed with martial arts and that was
in the trend like I got obsessed with
martial arts in like 81 so by the time
86 were all the rounds like what the
[ __ ] are you people paying attention to
yeah some guy dropped a ball you're
gonna be okay yeah what is this not only
that but that same year I believe it was
that same year the the Mets that same
year they paid the Patriots lost to the
Bears in a Super Bowl and they guy it
was one of the biggest blowouts in Super
Bowl history oh yeah they were riding
off of that - it was rough times times
for Boston yeah I I don't want to live
there because I can't deal with the cold
I'm
too much of a [ __ ] these days yeah but
I love those [ __ ] animals